ليس لدي أي مشاعر تجاه غزة لأنه لا ينبغي فصلها
ومن بين قتلة الأطفال مدنيو غزة
حرق المباني خير من هدمها
أن الجنود سوف يؤذون ولو عاصفة واحدة من رأسه
جندي في الجيش ليس لدي رحمة للناس
ومن بقي هناك عليه أن يخصم هذه النقطة
ليس لدي شك حتى في توقعاتك
أننا سوف نسقط ما يسمى بنوع من القنبلة الذرية
على غزة كلها يسويونها ويقضون على الجميع
إن التواجد فيه وبدون موجة هو طريقة أخرى
كما أنها تتحقق مما هو مهم بالنسبة لهم وما يخيفهم
ما الذي سيشكل رادعاً لهم بعد الحرب
وينبغي إدارة هذا بطريقة غير منظمة وغير منظمة
الأمور مضطربة جدًا للإلغاء والوعي
وينبغي لأعضاء الكنيست أيضاً أن يحتفلوا بانتصار حماس
سئل نسيم فيتوري من الليكود مرة أخرى أمس
في المقابلة بخصوص هذه التسميات التي ليست ضرورية
احرقوا غزة وهو يكرر ما قاله
يقول أنني لا أتنافس مع ذلك، أعتقد أنه ينبغي ذلك
حرق غزة لأنه حاليا في الأماكن التي
الجنود يقاتلون ولا يوجد مدنيون أبرياء
تحدثنا عن الممر الإنساني الذي قمنا بإخلائه بالفعل
وفي نفس البحر سمحنا لهم بالمغادرة هناك وبالتالي
في الوقت الحالي، لا يوجد مواطنون أبرياء، لكن يجب أن يقال
هذا حقا في هذا البيان أنني لا أريد ذلك
إن قول ما يلقيه المرء في النار لا يقوله كثير من الحكماء
لقد تمكنوا من إخراجها، وأعتقد أنه كان من الصعب سماع ذلك
مرات عديدة مزيج من الكلمات
إسرائيل بجوار الإبادة الجماعية إسرائيل ترتكب جريمة قتل ساخنة
الآن استمروا أيضًا في القول إنهم ليسوا نحن
لقد وصلنا إلى هذه القضية بعد خمس سنوات من وجود بعضها بالفعل
هناك وقف لإطلاق النار ولكن هدنة تحدث في إسرائيل حتى الآن
بينما نتحدث الآن، يُزعم أن مطالبتك تسبب Reg
منهجي للمواطنين الأبرياء ولكن لا بد من أن يقال
كان من الصعب مشاهدة العرض بأعينكم
ترى مناقشة عبارة عن جمل جاردا أو تابول
في السياسة وأيضا في التحيزات المتعمدة كيف حالك
رؤية أنني سأكون سعيدا إذا كان كثيرا
أكثر انغماسًا في السياسة أو على الأقل كان كذلك
في ظاهر الأمر، يبدو أكثر انغماساً في السياسة
لقد رأيت مناقشة قانونية رفيعة المستوى، لا
يجادلون، كما قال كيرين، بأنهم أيون
ما يسمى المنشأة وسأرى على الفور شيئا آخر
لكننا بالتأكيد رأينا هنا حجة فيما يتعلق
للادعاء الاستثنائي وفي رأيي خطأ تماما
الذي يزعمون أنه تم تقديمه بشكل جيد للغاية
لقد فوجئت بالأخطاء
حقائق الحصار الكامل على مدينة غزة
لا كهرباء، لا طعام، لا ماء، لا وقود نظيف
في الأطروحة 20 2 شراء الكهرباء قمنا بقطع الماء
الوقود لا يدخل أي شيء
إلى المدّعين الذين تشاجروا معي في الأمور السياسية
في المناظرات يقولون لموشيه أنه من الواضح أنه بحاجة إلى تدميره
كل الزيتون الموجود في شمال القطاع، على الأقل في الشمال
علينا أولاً أن نغزو القطاع ونضمه
تدمير جميع المنازل هناك لبناء الأحياء هناك
وانظر فقط كيف قال هؤلاء الأقوال
غير المسؤولين وغير الخطرين، وفي رأيي أيضاً غير المسؤولين
إن غير اليهود الذين سينطقون بهم هم نفس الذين يقرءونهم
إسرائيل لا تقف علة فهي حفنة من السم وهنا
ليس لدي سوى جملة واحدة أخرى، أيها الوزير
سموتريش والوزير ستروك وعضو الكنيست المحافظ ورفاقه
أدخل Gottlieb وأزل شؤون القنبلة الذرية
اميهاي الياهو هام حتى يتم كتابة القرار في Tzv
وفي غضون ذلك سيستمرون في قول ما يقولونه
لجعل القضاة يتأرجحون أيضًا وهناك سؤال
من يتأرجح ليحكم ضدنا هو مجموعة سم
يجب إيقافها ولا يستطيع نتنياهو حلها
نفسه من المسؤولية بفضل بعض الفكرة
في اللغة الإنجليزية نشر أمس أنه يجب أن يطرق
هذا على الطاولة أمام وزرائه المتطرفين
النتيجة مهمة جداً حتى لو كان هناك قرار
ضد إسرائيل من معها ومن ضدها
قرار مختلف تمامًا حيث يقول جميع القضاة
وقرار فيه قضاة من هذه الدول
الذين يقولون وإذا كان في أي مكان
نقطة أخيرة، شئنا أم أبينا
ما يحدث في العالم هو عواقب القرار السلبي
سيئة للغاية ضد
وربما تكون إسرائيل جادة للغاية
يمكن أن تفعل ما هو ممكن أرملة ليما
ويمكن القيام به